the first four pencils you spoke about
it seems like it's really under penned
by cottage which is of you spoke a lot
about yeah and cottage to a lot of
people individually within teams
business is a scary thing yeah what
would you see Foster's cottage is that
an internal thing as a neat or is that
something that you actually seek from
from the people around you yeah so in my
experience courage is an external thing
I've had the opportunity to meet people
who have risked their lives to save the
lives of others and they didn't have to
they weren't they would not have been
faulted if they didn't they were not
ordered to they may have violated orders
in fact to do so and I've had the chance
to ask them why did you do it and almost
unanimously they say because they would
have done it for me and it's the sense
that someone has my back that gives me
the courage to do something for them you
know if you're a world famous tightrope
walker and you wanted to try a brand new
death-defying act for the first time
you're gonna do it with a net it's not
your ability that gave you the courage
even though you're really good at it
it's the net it's this external thing
that gave you the courage and you build
it so so I think that the the to live us
to live with a servant's heart to be
that that leader that empathetic leader
what that engenders is that people start
to believe that you have their backs
that you would do something for them
that you would sacrifice your interests
to to protect them and miraculously
they'll do it back and the only thing
that makes you a leader is you're the
one who went first you're the one who
took the risk first right that's the
only thing that makes you the leader
leaders not because you have the rank we
call you leader because you literally
will lead you led us you went first
towards the danger to take the risk you
set the tone and people may have been
cynical at the start and you did it
again and they may have been cynical
again and you did it again and they
realized wait this is for real and weird
human things happened and they start to
offer you the same kind of love and
trust back I believe it's external and
I believe it's based on the quality of
human relationships which means it
doesn't happen overnight like in the
military they do not build the trust in
combat it's not when they step off the
plane with their rifles in arms do they
all trust each other it's in peacetime
where they're training and training and
training and training and learning to
love each other
the Israelis one of the most successful
militaries in military history the unit
that you train with when you're 18 years
old is your unit for the rest of your
life so when you're in your mid 40s and
you get called back for Reserve it's the
same people you trained with when you
were 18 years old because they're so
understand that the bonds that you form
when you're a kid that they want those
bonds throughout your entire military
career they understand where the trust
comes from so I believe that that that
we talk about human beings we forget
we're social animals you know there's an
entire section in the book shop called
self-help there is no section in the
book shop called help others and yet at
the end of the day by ourselves
we're crap like we're just not that good
by ourselves we're not that strong we're
not that clever but you give a team
together we can lift anything in solve
any problem not a single person on earth
solved any problem by themselves it
never happened and even if it was their
big brain there was somebody who
believed in them who gave them a break
or it funded them whatever it was they
did not do it alone and I think it's our
ability to foster relationships that
underpins the courage we need to do all
those difficult things
[Music]